people say I am the best boss
they go God we've never worked in a
place like this before you're hilarious
and you get the best out of us
um
I think that pretty much sums it up
I found it at Spencer Gifts
you know what I'm going to raise the
stakes
you know I want you to watch this
and I want you to burn this into your
brains
because this is an image
then I want you people to remember for a
long time to come whenever you come into
the office I want you to think about
this
we don't need to
yes we do what
oh
I did it
thank you thank you thank you see
I'm still here
foreign
we're all still here
oh come on Dwight come on man I think
that we could why are you crying yes I
think we should look into that you can
just speak up louder well no
I'll talk to her
I will no nobody talks to my baby that
way uh-uh yeah I'll let you know how it
goes
all right bye pickle
Pamela Morgan Beasley you need to
apologize to your mother right now I'm
sorry I was told I had the floor yes
hold on what's going on nothing
nothing at all it's all good I'm not
apologizing to anyone
Michael owes me an apology for trying to
find happiness in the arms of a lover
don't call my mother your lover oh yes
that's what I'm talking about
the not okay dude in my defense
disgusting she's messed up man yes thank
you welcome my personal hell you have no
sense of boundaries shut up Oscar you
know what
I love Phyllis
no one else
I think she is gorgeous I think she is
an incredibly incredibly attractive
person
come here come here come on oh my God
come on you don't have to worry I'm not
reported I'm not worried HR you know
what the only thing I am worried about
is getting a boner
good work today everybody
come on Michael you're you're
interrupting you're kidding me God
you say right on as silent but deadly
and then you expect me not to make
farting noises with my mouth what is
this you know what we're not gonna die
of radon we're going to die boredom yeah
right and if I had a gun with two
bullets and I was in a room with Hitler
Bin Laden and Toby I would shoot Toby
twice
okay all right really funny and then you
went too far I would kill Bin Laden and
then Toby no it's still Pam can you come
in here for a second
let's have a seat I was gonna call you
in anyway
um you know Ryan
there's going to be downsizing and uh
you have made my life
so much easier
in that I am going to have to let you go
first
what why
well theft
stealing stealing
um what am I supposed to have stolen
Post-it notes
Post-it notes what are those worth like
50 cents 50 cents yeah you steal a
thousand Post-it notes at 50 cents a
piece and you know you've made a profit
margin you know go run us out of
business Pam
are you serious
um I can't believe this I mean I've
never even stolen as much as a paper
clip and now you're firing me
but the best thing about it is that uh
We're not gonna have to give you any
severance pay
because that is
gross misconduct and uh because I just
clean out your desk I'm sorry
human ex-punk
surprise it's a joke we were joking
around see okay he was in on it he was
my accomplice and
there was just kind of a morale booster
thing and we were showing the new guy
around kind of kind of giving him the
feel of the place
so
God you were we totally got you you're a
jerk
I don't know about that
why don't you go in there Dwight and
find these people a plan that'll work
for them okay I can handle it okay
all right
we feel good
all right good
Plus
there's some other good news
today at the end of the day I will have
for all of you
a big surprise okay so hang in there and
I will see you at the end of the day
I think we should go because I don't
know Kevin I mean this is important I
don't want serious
what is he doing I don't know
well
well what
you could be referring to anything
okay
the healthcare plan why did you put
Dwight in charge of that he did a
horrible job uh Dwight
did you raise benefits I most certainly
did not oh come on that's horrible dog
thanks Dwight for a crappy plan
ah damn
oh I wish I had time to change it but
Jay needs it by five and what time is it
what time is it well it's after five uh
oh it's awful
so well okay see you guys uh on Monday
what about the surprise oh yes
exactly thank you Angela for reminding
me
terrific
um before I tell everybody what the big
surprise is would you like to tell me
what you think the big surprise is
we all think you don't have a surprise
all right I have some news for you
there is a big surprise
and
here it is here we go and
the big surprise is
drumroll
[Music]
okay
you guys got it soft and cushy this
place is freaking awesome the People Are
Awesome your boss is nice everybody
seems to get along people are tolerant
people who have jumped to conclusions
can redeem themselves
nobodies nobody's I hope that this
scared you and for me prison Mike to you
I just want to thank you for listening
to me
and letting me be a part of your life
today
because you got a good life
you got a good life
a good life
so what do you think it doesn't sound so
great does it
thank you
um that must been hard for you to relive
that both of you
yeah that
wasn't really at all my experience and
there's certain elements of what you've
performed I've seen on television
but it didn't remind me of my time in
prison
okay okay fine
you guys think prison is so great all
right
well
here you go okay Michael come on no if
you think prison is so wonderful then
enjoy prison
they are such babies I am going to leave
them in there until they can appreciate
what it's like to have freedom
and if this doesn't bother them then I
am out of ideas
foreign